so quick agenda we're going to talk
about the performance improvements of
page p8 uh we're going to talk about
some of the new features page b8 has a
lot of new features but unfortunately we
don't have the time uh we're going to
talk about a couple of changes that we
have made to page b8 breaking changes
this is very important because
this is what's going to dictate how easy
is going to be for you to update to page
v8 or not
we're going to talk about some internal
changes that we made uh that probably
you're not going to see in your daily
work but it's going to affect some
people that maintain libraries for
example
that mean hello how are you doing
um
and also some behind the scenes of hph
development uh because this was the
first version of php that i that i
followed the development from beginning
to end uh so i have a couple of stuff to
talk with you
and let's get started performance
improvements um i think the biggest the
most famous uh and i think the selling
point of php is gonna be the just in
time so
just in time
is something
very complex very big but very important
for the language which is going to
improve a lot the performance of your
applications but i want to highlight one
thing if you already have very very fast
apis let's say that you have an api that
is returning and processing everything
in 20 30 100 milliseconds those apis
they're not going to be affected by just
in time because just in time is focused
on have process so for example if you're
doing machine learning if you're doing
blockchain if you're doing i don't know
image processing with php and that those
processes are taking like forever
jit is gonna be the one
which is going to improve those
performance but for your apis um
it's not it's not going to be that much
um oh wow okay so damian has read a
benchmark uh so exact which is a stacked
analyzer to got 50 improvements from hp
7428 this is amazing
unfortunately i don't have any
benchmarks because um benchmarking jit
is not that trivial uh so
once we start to have new versions of
hp80801802 and then we start to have
benchmarks then for sure we're gonna see
how important and how big those
performance improvements are
uh
as i said we have a limited amount of
time and jit by itself is huge uh and
venua got me covered so benoit uh he
spoke last year at forum hp uh in french
so it's gonna be way easier for you to
understand uh he talked about everything
about jit uh but i found a
very nice talks in the internet so i
have uh one for my colleague in brazil
um we have nikita popov we're gonna talk
about this one
uh in the end of the talk dmitry which
was the developer uh of jit in russian
so you have four flavors four languages
that you wanna uh that you wanna you can
see on youtube which are dedicated g
talks uh and then you're gonna see why
is important how was developed how you
configured how you benchmark uh what's
gonna affect your applications and and
so on unfortunately i don't have the
time but they got me covered we already
have a bunch of content on the internet
about it
uh and those were the performance
improvements uh of hp8 we have a couple
of small ones uh but i want to i don't
spend my time on it because which is the
biggest one and those those are these
this is where you should focus your
effort to
uh talking about features uh of hp8 we
have a lot we have a bunch of new
features on page b8 uh we have more
features in php b70
in numbers of what we call rfcs which is
the formal processing of bringing
something to the php
but
we're not going to talk about everything
we're going to talk about four
attributes union types the match uh
we're going to talk about it and name it
arguments and let's start with union
types
so if you're not familiar with human
types um
is basically that mathematical concept
of union so you have one thing or
another combined
so in this example we have
unit types on lines 5 8 and 14 in
properties
methods
and also return types parameters and
also return types but as you can see
this is documented this is not real
union types we are talking about page
p74
code here or page b whatever
and if you try to use this code and you
you online 22 you're passing a string
um oh there's another page p8 jit talk
oh thank you for for sharing uh i didn't
know that one i'm gonna i'm gonna add to
my list uh so in this example if you're
using um
this class it's not going to work
because there's no real validation uh
what you can do before page p8 is um
sanitize and treat those inputs so is it
an integer is either a float
then if it's not then you throw an
exception
you have seen this this pattern in a lot
of codes uh but in page p8 you're going
to be able to type your code
with unit types properties arguments uh
return types everything that were
documented in in the past now it's going
to be real type it and in this example
if we try now to use this class passing
a string we're going to have a native
type we're going to have a native uh
error from hp saying hey this was
supposed to be either integer or a float
but you're passing string so this is a
huge advance for the php type system um
uh we have others
we have other uh uh additions to unit
types and other additions to the type
system of hp8 but eunon types is the
biggest one um one thing you can use as
many unit types as you want
uh here you can see that we have more
than five unit types in this case and it
works just fine of course you can't
repeat because that's going to trigger
an error
but
you can use that php a page building
types as many as you want but we also
have mix it
which was
something
that a lot of people were like why do we
need it do we need it uh and my opinion
on mix it is uh we're gonna use
mix it as a as a bridge so you bring a
php seven four code where you don't have
type at all you type as mix it and then
with time you start to
specify those types so i have three
types i have two types i have four types
and this is how you improve the typing
of your or the type coverage of your
code let's put it that way um
yeah i have take a break on twitter man
tweet twitter was going so crazy with
corona and everything um but yeah i
still have twitter my my dms are open so
if you just want to ask me uh go ahead
uh mix it will be any of php yes
actually any uh was uh considered as the
other uh from javascript right either we
have mixed it or any
but any is not that common on page on
php code page documentation mix it was a
common one so we decided to go from mix
it because then people can just uh
convert the annotations that they have
uh to real types uh thanks sebastian for
being the one sebastian
and that that's xenotype i hope you guys
are excited as i am about unit types
because that's going to bring a lot of
improvements for the
for the language but it's not about just
that page paid we have also match which
is a new um structure in page b and what
is a structure if you take for example
switch if else uh for loops those are
structures and match is a new one it's
been a while since we have added a an
extractor to php
but what is match um match is an
alternative to switch because switch has
some flaws uh to switch it php switch is
not the best thing in the world um
together with other stuff
but um
what is what are the problems uh this is
one problem that we have with switch
on line three we have value as a string
and on line 12 we have case two as
integer and php consider this thing as
equal
and switch uses equal
by under the hood
which
some people don't think is is right
because switch should be strictly
compared uh so using the triple sign
instead of the two signs
um
but you know
changing switch is is not fundamental is
is a very ex is a structure that is used
like broadly in the ecosystem so it's
not that trivial to change it
uh and also there is another thing if
you pass us a case that does not exist
on page piece uh switch is it's just
going to throw your warning instead of
saying hey you're missing a default here
so instead of instead of telling you
that it's gonna say hey you're just
missing the valuable result
which you know for debugging purpose is
not the best thing
so we have match on hp8
i like your hoodie thank you uh yeah
it's a hp8 hoodie a special edition i'm
going to talk about that later on um and
then we have a hp8 match uh match is
again something that we brought from
other languages
and um watches is basically an
alternative to switch in terms of is
more strict
is faster uh i'm not going to talk into
how fast it is but it's faster um and
also it covers a lot of the flaws the
switch has so for example here now we
have value as shoe and the case of match
is also true
and you can echoing out a match switch
you need to assign to a variable do a
lot of stuff and then you do whatever
you want with a variable match is an
expression that you can use together
with echo so is is way better
and also if you pass something to match
which does not exist a case
it's going to throw an error this is
something amazing because during
development time you're gonna exhaust
all the possibilities that you have with
your match uh of recursion you still can
have a default but let's say that you
don't you don't wanna default like i
want to exhaust all the options page pin
now is gonna tell you during development
time this is amazing
to avoid
those production errors they are like
small ones but of course this tech
analyzer who would caught it
but
matches here um and i think is here to
stay
the third one that i want to talk about
today is named arguments um what is
named arguments if you use phpstorm you
know what i'm talking about but i'm
gonna consider that no one uses hp storm
um and i'm gonna take this example uh to
illustrate what is naming arguments you
we have a function called array
filtering page b
which is very trivial to understand if
you walk through this code you have an
array of items you want to filter the
items on line seven which are integers
and then on line nine we have uh the two
items of those that array
that are integers
and it's not that difficult to
understand you have one argument two
arguments but then you have a function
that we don't use daily right at least i
don't use daily which is array fill
you have two three and page p like what
the hell those arguments are supposed to
say
imagine
this is the output by the way uh you
have like two php three hp for page p so
if you try to understand
2 is the index that is going to start
array 3 is the number of items of that
array and page p is the value of all
those items
but imagine if you could do this
starting key as to the number of items
in that array as free and then you have
the value of each argument as page b
it's way easier to understand right so
you have um
this in page bit we
we're gonna name uh all the arguments of
our um uh functions methods and
everything so you can document your code
and it's gonna improve the readability
of it uh named arguments or anonymous
arguments uh named arguments anonymous
arguments i never heard about that if
you can say it later on what it is i
have never heard them sorry
uh so moving on uh it's not just about
functions it's also about
classes arguments methods and everything
in this example we have string name and
string h works just fine
in this case we have an interface and we
have an implementation of this interface
and if you take a look at line 5 and
line 10
we have renamed instead of name we have
name as full name
so what are we going to use php is going
to follow the rename so if you rename a
class
a class um sorry a methods uh parameter
it's gonna force you to use the renaming
one if you didn't know that php allows
you to do that don't do it because it's
not a common best price but if you do uh
it's gonna follow the rename um
naming arguments is very good for
booleans uh uh um um constructors if
they're good or not this is another
discussion but for example online 14 you
have new user true false and no like how
the hell
what what true means what false means
what does numing
and if you have named arguments is way
easier to understand i have a user which
is anatomy which is not active and they
are not um
it has no rules so this is easier to
understand when you have naming
arguments and this is what hpa is
bringing um i have a slide here which uh
covers all the uh permutations uh that
you can have with naming arguments you
can have a random order this is the
biggest
advantage of naming arguments you don't
need to follow the order of the
arguments anymore uh if you have
optional arguments you can specify one
or another in this case the to both
arguments one and two they are optionals
uh but you just want to change the value
of the argument two so this is easier
uh with uh naming arguments this is
actually possible just because of name
arguments and you can skip
if you start if you don't start with
name arguments and then later on you
decided to use name arguments um
for example here on line 13. this is
allowed
but if you decided not to use and then
you use it again on argument two but
then on argument three you don't use it
this is not allowed because php lost
tracks uh lost track uh on how to to
analyze this thing so you need to
follow either
everything or don't skip it because it's
not going to work
and that's name and arguments
uh a couple of questions
um can we mix it name your arguments and
normal arguments some methods call yeah
this is what i have just showed here
um and then the last feature that i want
to talk about hp8 is attributes and you
probably know attributes as annotations
decorators and a bunch of other names
that other languages have
but in php is going to call attributes
and attributes
see it as
annotations or something that gives your
class your properties your variables
are properties attributes um and here we
have an example with doctrine so this
class is an entity and both properties
they are a columns and the first uh and
the private and the property id is
is an id
you can do that with annotations
nowadays
but
think that every single project that
once you have this
mechanism needs to implement its own
an annotation or attributes library
doctrine has a famous one doctrine
annotations uh if you work with
serialization if you work with symphony
all those all those products they have
their own implementation
so what if we could centralize that in
php and php brought that um so just a
quick disclaimer
annotations uh is something that we use
to document our code and attributes is
something that we use to give
attributes to classes to properties and
and so on um and then on page p8 we're
gonna have something like this it's very
similar to annotations but are not
annotations they're attributes and this
is gonna be checked by page piece engine
by php source code so now
we're we can cache we can validate we
can um uh extend we can implement we can
do a lot of stuff with with attributes
and it's very similar um um this is a
this is the syntax that was chosen um
and this is the rust like syntax but
it's very similar to what we have
nowadays
and it's gonna work on hp8 we're gonna
have attributes native uh this is gonna
help a lot uh some projects they have
custom implementations uh some
frameworks and so on we're gonna have
caching optimization as i said uh and
annotations are gonna be for
documentation and attributes are gonna
be for attributes themselves
one click disclaimer and one important
thing
attributes needs to be supported by your
uh library framework or whatever you're
using php is not going to convert
automatically annotations
to attributes
your projects need to support that there
is a whole section in the rfc document
that proposed this thing how you can
implement that using reflection um and
there you go these are the four biggest
features
of
of hp yeah python python even goes even
further and allows you to rename
internally or externally but hp only
allows you to use them
the name that you give to the api
but that's something for later on uh
some changes uh it's not breaking
changes but are changes to page p8
um
previously if you try to use fro as an
expression you couldn't now on page b8
you can so know all those ifs if
something is not set throw an exception
now you can do i can either have the
variable
nullable or throw an exception
you can have exceptions on short
closures and a lot of other things
that before php you weren't allowed
uh but now we have made this change to
troll uh which is not a breaking change
it's just a change and it's gonna
simplify a lot of code um from um
from a lot of stuff can you mix comment
and attribute yes that's that's allowed
but keep in mind that if your project
does not support attributes it's not
going to work
another small change to page p8 uh some
people have uh very specific exceptions
uh and they use exception domains
and they don't need the exception uh the
exception object because this is handler
by the air handling by some some
upstream project that is taking care of
exceptions
so they don't need the variable now this
is allowed you can catch an exception
without passing the variable
and then just throw whatever you need
this is a small change but people ask we
have made it is there
one important change this is not a
breaking change but this is a
deprecation warning
if you take a look at line three we have
something that is not right
which is an optional argument followed
by a required argument
it's not because php allows you to do
that that you should this is not right
if you take all the books everything
about the pen's injection about
computer science and everything
you should first declare your required
arguments and then your optional
arguments because this is how you treat
an api right
but hp allow you to do that so we have
some folks out there which have done
this in the past uh but this is
deprecated on page p8 and it's going to
be removed all the way on page p9 so
you're going to have a couple of
versions to fix this uh don't don't get
crazy if you see these deprecation
warnings at first these are those
application work but take take in
consideration that you need to fix this
for hp9 in the future this is going to
be removed in a future major version of
page b but this is deprecated on page b
eight
uh as i said this is a deprecation one
now the important break compatibility
changes and this is how you're going to
see how difficult is going to be for you
to upgrade your code from your whatever
version you're using to page p8
first one
everything that was removed or that it
was deprecated sorry in the page p 1 0 2
3 and 4 is now removed on page p8 so if
you were using anything that was
deprecated on page p7
and page but it's not going to work
because it's removed
there is an extensive list here you can
check the official prerequest on the php
source code is open source
there is everything but just keep in
mind if you're using something that was
duplicated now it's removed simple as
that
this one
apart from being a release manager of
hp8 i also did some contributions to hp8
and this was my one sorry i break your
code but this this example illustrates
uh something that was allowed in the in
the past but now hp is not going to be
allowed anymore
magic methods of page b
in the past they weren't being validated
how you
type them so in the past you could have
such thing as a class 4 with a method to
string retaining a boolean this is not
right it's supposed to return a string
so on hp8 we're going to
type and check we're going to check
if you type your magic method it's not
required it's not mandatory if you don't
use types with php you can still don't
use them but if you use we're going to
check them there's an extensive list on
this rfc which is the formal document
that we propose to page internals
to change page b
uh and we're gonna
you you're gonna have all the lists with
all the changes that you you need to
make um to
to make your magic methods work
um
this one
i hope you agree with me that dividing
an empty array with an array that is 42
makes zero sense
in the past page p would return you zero
one or our number uh but you know it
doesn't make sense so we have remove it
it's not working anymore on page p8 the
same way if we try to increment a class
if you try to implement an array and
that's not going to work okay this is
removing page p8 um stack analyzer tools
um for example damien's one which is
exact um page b style and possum fan all
the stack analyzer tools that we have in
the php ecosystem
all of them were already reporting this
uh in previous versions so if you're
using stack analyzer tool don't worry
about these changes because it's not
gonna affected you
uh and last but not least this is the
biggest breaking change of page p8 uh
more specific on line six
uh there there is a whole meme in the
community saying
zero is equal to full yeah for php in
the past it was true but now it's not
true any longer okay uh zero is not a is
is not equal to a string in any sense um
except
except for uh uh integers and floats
because that makes sense but like empty
strings strings with stuff this is true
in the past but now is false and this is
going to break a lot of code
but again
don't use
double sign okay use the triple sign
have types in your code this is this is
going to make your life way easier but
if you do use the the double equal sign
pay attention because if you're doing
this kind of comparison it's going to
break your code uh and the last one uh
which i don't think shouldn't impact a
lot of people but it's a breaking change
uh php in the past would cast uh uh a
string which is ties with a number to
just the number so this is why 42 is
equal to 42 full because php casts 42
full to 44 42.
um but this is not no longer true and
this is gonna break your code
uh if you have such thing okay
um
those are the breaking changes um uh
some internal changes that i want to
share with you i'm gonna hurry uh with
these lives because i'm getting out of
time um but there's an api on page p
called reflection which basically tells
you everything that you want to know
about um a function a class a property
of a class um and so on
before page p8 if you try for example to
reflect the function array filter
you would have no type information at
all like what is the type of the first
argument what is the type of the second
argument what is the return type of ray
filter previously none zero you had no
information on page b8 you're gonna have
[ __ ] tons of information every single
um internal function now is typed this
was a forest task it was amazing it was
painful to add support to everything but
if you have for example uh a library
which is using reflection and you were
demanding these things uh now is uh and
now is is is in the source code of hp8
uh there are a couple of parties there
were that depends on this uh and there's
a project from jetbrains uh which is
specifically for this thing um and
probably they're gonna deprecate this
project in the future because now we
have this information on page ph source
code
and then you can check it out the the
slides layer but it's basically
a
api that php has
which is reflection which tells you a
lot of information
again this is an internal change
probably you're not going to use this
thing in your daily work but if you
maintain a library that depends on
reflection
you're going to
you know what i'm talking about i'm
talking with you that maintains a
library it depends on reflection and you
don't have type information now you have
it's such an improvement for the
language was huge was painful was long
but we made it it's there
and the last topic i have two minutes to
talk about this thing um which are the
behind the scenes of hp8
we have a couple of people which is
behind php um as i got introduced it i'm
one of the release managers of hp8 uh
this is the hp8 logo by the way a lot of
people are asking if this is the
official one yes this is the official
one which was made by a french which i
forgot his name if someone remembers his
name vincent vincent was the creator of
the elephants the designer of the
elephants and he also designed a page b7
logo and he also designed the hp8 logo
so
this is why i have this hoodie uh so we
have two release managers sarah and i uh
we are responsible for taking care of
the php-8
release cycle making sure that every
four weeks we have a new release of hp
we need to make sure that everything is
working everything is buildable
everything is free of bugs which we
can't but um i ran out of time
so let's hurry up
uh i just give i just want to give a
couple of shout outs uh to some
contributors of the php source code uh
which are dmitri he was the creator of
jit nikita he's working on behalf of
jetbrains in the source code he has done
more than 10 rfcs which is amazing um we
have christoph which is doing the bridge
between microsoft and php um
so if you run hp on windows this is the
one that is is is allowing you to do
that uh we have jacob with his taking
care of the fpm uh um
sup of php uh we have mateo which
organized the php day in italy he's
taking care of the patio extension we
have tyson which works for fan which is
a stack analyzer too um
uh and he's he's bringing a lot of stuff
to the php source code we have these two
gentlemen that they were the ones that
helped us uh to do the reflection uh
forest tech that i mentioned we have
imagine changing
2 000
plus functions in a language to have
type information so this should we work
around the clock to have that
information add to the source code those
are the ones that helped you um
all these all these names they are
clickable you can go to their github and
also they have github sponsors so if you
want to sponsor php
to keep evolving
here's an example of how you should do
that we have new contributors uh alex
was the first african contributor that
we had uh uh hence in the fact that hp
is an open source global language he was
the first african contributor that we
had uh we have elijah
uh which he is uh
not a maintainer but a contributor to
paige piston he also made a lot of
contributions to php8 for example match
he was the one that created a match so
if you want to thanks him um
he's the one and we also have some
famous people uh beijing from doctrine
he was the one that created attributes
and we have nicholas which is a french
one um which he is the member of
symphony he also contributes to hp8 he
made an interface called stringable
and yeah we have we have even the
community uh
doctoring symphony laravel whatever uh
up
giving back to php and improving php
source code so this is this is huge this
is amazing
unfortunately i need to rush because we
have very limited amount of time but um
i'm going to share these lies with you
there's a whole
document that i have created
which is
everything that i have found in terms of
uh um
reference for page b8 all the official
references blog posts around there all
the talks that i have found um uh all
the rfcs every everything that has
changed inside a php source code you're
gonna have the links here uh so there's
a lot of things that you need to go
through if you wanna support hp8 um
but yeah page page is here hph is there
hp is gonna come on the end of november
i'm so excited is a new major version of
hp is a new cycle is a new era as i like
to say uh for php page p8 is coming and
uh is here to stay is here to prove that
php is not that page p is evolving page
b is growing php is going to become a
huge language in the future i can't wait
um
to php to grow even more
and that's it
unfortunately i didn't have the time to
talk about everything so please go check
out these lights um
we have a bunch of reference uh that you
can that you can see uh and one thing
that i ask you uh give me feedback uh if
i can
click this link as i can um because with
this feedback i can improve
my talk
for the next conference and uh